la femme de mon frère akan signé monia
chokri à remporter ce prix coup de coeur
implique privilégie la cinéaste
elle a présenté son film mais hier au
public montréalais ont dit que c'était
absolument chaleureux ce sera à québec
au club le 3 juin à sherbrooke vendredi
le 7 juin où monia chokri se rendre à on
est très content de l'avoir avec nous ce
soir pour lui demander au fond si un
avant et un après cannes et comment elle
perçoit aussi l'avenir du cinéma
québécois d'après un premier film et
avait d'autres courts métrages y avait
belle comédienne aussi bonsoir mon
invité de cette émission c'est quand
même un jour triste pour le cinéma
québécois ou bien le reconnaître
jean claude labrecque à 80 ans
à quelques jours de ce grand gala du
cinéma québécois sans l'avoir connu
personnellement qu'est ce que vous savez
de lui et il quand même une inspiration
bain une totalement est directement
parce que je parle du cinéma direct qui
est pour moi une inspiration majeure
dans mon travail
surtout pour ce travail de direction
photo donc il ya fait le show dans le
sac et a fait rentrer la mairie l'eau
douce il ya participé aussi à l'image de
la tout prendre donc c'est des films
fondateurs pour moi pour ma psyché
créatrice donc puis c'est un cinéma
auquel on s'est éloigné dans les années
80 90 2000 au québec
et moi je me fais vraiment porteuse de
redonner les lettres de noblesse à ce
cinéma l'appuyer dans de l'intégrer dans
mon propre film et ça se sent d'ailleurs
dans la famille de mon frère vous voyez
vraiment les éléments le riz sont des
hommages à ce cinéma là
quinon notamment l'intégration du
documentaire ou des effets de style de
par exemple d'avoir des voix qui sont
pas coller à l'image en face et des
petites choses qui sont pour moi des
hommages à ce cinéma le premier long
métrage auriez-vous cru avoir déjà une
telle une telle reconnaissance pour
votre style vos choix artistiques c'est
toujours compliqué de dire ça parce que
quand on est dans la création on se
demande pas qu'est ce qui va arriver
après en fait on ne peut pas penser
comme sans danger faire un film pour
aller à cannes évidemment qu'on y rêve
quand on est cinéaste quand on fait du
cinéma d'auteur
ça fait partie de nos envies c'est un
peu les un peu j un peu tristement mais
c'est ça fait une comparaison idiote
mais c'est un peu comme les olympiques
pour les athlètes à dire que pour les
cinéastes d'aller à caen c'est un peu le
la panacée donc c'est évidemment que
c'est quelque chose auquel on rêve
après ça je pouvais pas imaginer qu'ils
m'offraient l'ouvrir d'ouverture du
certain regard qu'il y aura cet honneur
donc oui j'en suis ravi que parce qu'il
ya un lien entre le fait d'avoir un prix
coup de coeur et ce qu'on voit à chaque
seconde à chaque image de votre film qui
viennent nous surprendre nous dégoûter
même parfois nous interroger non il ya
aussi et bien ça se soit accroché comme
les atomes ouais ben en tous les cas
c'est sûr que moi ça me touche le prix
coup de coeur moi j'en ai fait souvent
des jurys puis ce prix les quelque chose
de particulier parce que c'est bon c'est
pas le grand prix mais c'est parce que
souvent les grands prix finalement sont
des prix de de concession entre ce que
tout le monde a émis de manière sans
fard deux enfin j'ai quelque chose
d'autre dans le coup de coeur alors que
je sais que dans le coup de coeur et
qu'est-ce qu'on veut pas laisser passer
ouais je deviens un amour comme naturel
pour le film c'est vrai que j'ai fait un
film avec enfin avec toute la sincérité
du monde puis j'ai voulu en faire
quelque chose pour le public
alors michel de coulon qui j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure parce qu'ils étaient ces
pourparlers de jean-claude n'a pas eu de
chance aux chansons à savoir monia
chokri manger j'ai adoré ce film dit
michel coulombe
j'ai senti l'urgence elle a tout mis sur
la table
ouais parce que c'était un peu différent
oui mais c'est ça enfin premiers films
souvent à cette tendance puis jean jé
pas échappé de vouloir tout dire donc
c'est vrai qu'il ya quelque chose il ya
quelque chose après c'est pas de
l'autobiographie mais il ya quelque
chose de tout tout maison angoisse ou et
tout mais ça regarde lucidement
peut-être un peu critique même de cette
génération
ouais ben oui c'est moi c'était aussi
que je me disais moi je suis né aussi
d'un parent immigrants dont qui en une
génération en fait j'ai aussi je me suis
complètement occidentalisée j'ai
complètement oublié tout le parcours
aussi qu'on fait de passer du
tiers-monde aussi arrivé dans le monde
occidental
il y avait aussi à une critique de ce
peut-être de m'ordonner de revenir à ses
racines puis de revenir à l'étranger
pour pouvoir être plus plus tolérants ou
et plus aisément et michel dit la
direction d'acteurs est fabuleuse
alors mais ça ça s'invente poste il faut
que vous ayez ce talent là
dans tous les cas c'est olivier vis des
bons acteurs oui j'étais très bon parce
que oui après ceux ci c'est un ballet
qui se fait entre la réalisation puis le
jeu mais c'est quelque chose qui m'a
toujours plu j'ai commencé au
conservatoire déjà j'aimais dirigé dans
les petites saynètes des choses comme ça
donc j'ai toujours explorer ça mon
espèce de vocabulaire subtil suggestives
ou directives et je déciderai que je
respecte mais je travaille vraiment moi
j'essaie de créer une espèce de bulle où
l'acteur ressentir le mieux comme moi
j'aimerais me sentir sur un plateau un
mot sur ce que vous représentiez pour le
québec à cannes les gens à qui on
parlait autour de nous parce qu'on
attendait ça prend en compte fait
vraiment fier de voir cette bande de
jeunes les sciences de photos faisait-il
tous ensemble même avec david holland sa
bande à lui la vôtre ensemble cette
fierté d'avoir à cannes en europe jeune
génération qui
offre notre culture puisqu'on fait plus
beau fond nos artisans nos créations
mais là je vous ce sentiment là des oufs
vent de fraîcheur sur cannes évidemment
nous on n'arrive pas en vain on est les
représentantes on n'est pas des on est
pas des ministres on est pas on n'est
pas des représentants politiques
on est des artistes est plus doux mais
oui je sais pas enfin ça dépend des
artistes mais mais ce qui est important
c'est que nous on représente pas des
nations on est là pour rassembler les
nations c'est ça aussi qui est beau à
cannes c'est que tous les peuples sont
ensemble et il communique dans un
langage commun qui est le cinéma et
l'image
donc c'est voilà si si si en plus on
fait honneur à notre nation entre
guillemets notre culture ben c'est tant
mieux si ça permet de faire rayonner
monia chokri merci d'être passé sur le
plateau en direct ce soir
[Musique]
à bientôt
piaggio cinéma sherbrooke et 17 juin
félicitations encore une première on
partage sur coup de coeur merci ni
rejaillit sur nous